Westerners have a hard time
understanding that the basic structure
of Chinese society is fundamentally
different from the West and by that I
mean individuals do not exist in China
outside of their obligations and
responsibilities to other people so
individualism in a Western sense and by
that I mean society encouraging you to
define yourself independent of society
doesn't exist on the other hand China is
a Confucian society so it's also very
ambitious
so egos are huge so on the surface
Chinese want to be Western individualism
is very aspirational but it's ultimately
forbidden fruit I always call it Eve's
Apple so as China becomes modern the way
they express their place in society
seems Western but in actuality it's
conforming to Chinese imperatives of
generating acknowledgement for your
contribution to society most Westerners
who have any idea at all of Confucian
society they tend to think of it as very
hierarchical regimented rule-bound
restrictive that's true to a certain
extent but Confucian society was also
the world's first socially mobile
society by mastering the system by being
able to navigate the rules and become a
connoisseur of the rules you could climb
yourself up a socially mandated
hierarchy of success so there's a
tension in Confucian society that's
really quite dramatic and that's between
on one hand regimentation but on the on
the other hand ambition this tension
between regimentation and ambition leads
to what I would consider the golden rule
of marketing and brand consumption in
China which is that people want to stand
out by fitting in and that means that
people want to project their status but
at the same time do so in a way that
protects themselves from any aberrant
moves or any overt rebellion so Chinese
people are willing to spend a lot of
money on goods that can be seen by the
public whether it be a mobile phone or a
car or even shiny hair but when it comes
to anything that is privately consumed
it's going to be very a price sensitive
so this public consumption imperative
leads to a lot of different business
models I mean you take a look at the way
Starbucks has succeeded in China with
over 1500 stores that's because they
have reconfigured those sites to be
public destination sites where bands of
new generation professionals go in there
together to proclaim their affiliation
with a new generation elite so this
projection of status drives a lot of
multinational brands business strategy
on the other hand however when you
project status you can't do it so
obviously so Chinese are looking to
project their status in an understated
way that's why Chinese women for example
love diamonds because they sparkle they
don't glare so the sparkle captures
attention but it does so with a whisper
or the Montblanc pen for the man why do
people like the Montblanc pen they like
it because of that six pointed star
that's very obviously but still somehow
discreetly placed at the top of the the
cap so the simple act of putting a pen
in your pocket says something about the
man that he's in charge and he's a
master of something and this projection
of status but in an understated way this
public consumption over private
consumption as it relates to price
premiums and what people are willing to
pay for them as an investment in their
status drives a lot of the consumption
habits that you see in China
you